20:17 is shaping up to be a great year
for movies with a ton of cool films
already on the schedule in fact so many
great movies are coming out next year we
thought you might need a jumpstart on
planning here's a look at the movies you
won't want to miss in 2017 winter
februar wants the dumping ground for
Hollywood's biggest failures but in 2017
the action heats up with the
long-awaited big-screen adaptation of
Stephen King's Dark Tower series
starring Indra Selva as the iconic
gunslinger how awesome is that and if
that wasn't enough the Dark Knight
Returns once again with the Lego Batman
movie maybe this time he can finally
save his parents where's the seat belt
the first lesson is life doesn't give
you seat belt spring in March you can
look forward to Kong Skull Island which
brings the legendary eight forward into
the 1970s for a showdown with samuel
l.jackson and Tom Hiddleston meanwhile
superhero fans will get the next
installment in the seemingly
never-ending series of x-men films with
yet another Wolverine flick but the
biggest film of the spring is
undoubtedly April's fast eight which
reunites everyone's favorite
multicultural team of rebels with an
equally sleek and sexy array of fast
cars American filmmaking at its absolute
peak summer in May Marvel's hotly
anticipated space romp guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 sets the tone for a summer
of fantastic sequels including
follow-ups for Pirates of the Caribbean
World War Z Kingsman transformers cars
and Despicable Me but they're all
overshadowed by the June arrival of
Wonder Woman which finally brings one of
the world's greatest superheroes to the
big screen in the movie event of the
year
DC's film efforts have a pretty poor
track record with a critic so far but
Wonder Woman looks like it may finally
change all that
awesome so does Marvel have an answer
for Wonder Woman of course it's your
friendly neighborhood spider-man I'd
love to keep this up but I've only got
one job here today and I got to impress
mr. stark so I'm really sorry
July's spiderman homecoming is the first
Spidey film produced by Marvel Studios
as part of their shared cinematic
universe so it'll be interesting to see
how it plays out and if you're feeling
burnt out on superhero films and sequels
don't worry because July also brings
legendary director Christopher Nolan's
gritty new war drama Dunkirk fall in
August Ridley Scott returns with the
newest piece of the alien universe with
alien covenant which despite its title
is actually a sequel to 2012's
Prometheus and another ridley scott sci
fi ed pick gets a sequel with the
follow-up to 1982 s Blade Runner nobody
has any idea what to expect from it but
whether it's awesome or a total train
wreck you definitely don't want to miss
it
holidays three massive blockbusters
anchor the 2017 holiday movie season so
you know exactly what to ask Santa for
next year
November starts with the release of Thor
Ragnarok which also features the Hulk
November continues with DC's answer to
the Avengers Justice League the bones
then think you are real I'm real on it's
useful but as big as both of those
movies are guaranteed to be both will be
dwarfed by the December 15 release of
one of the most highly anticipated films
of all time
Star Wars Episode eight will Luke
actually talk this time we can't wait to
find out thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know which
movie you're looking forward to most in
2017
[Music]